[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara guten abend schön dass sie dabei
sind wie auch norbert könig für den
sportler guten abend und das sind einige
unserer themen heute
mehr zusammenarbeit kein neuer kalter
krieg in seiner ersten rede als
us-präsident vor der uno vollversammlung
spricht joe biden von einer neuen ära
der diplomatie
ein streit ums masken tragen mit
tödlichem ende in einer tankstelle in
idar oberstein erschießt ein gegner der
korona maßnahmen einen kassierer
und erdbeben und ein neuer lavastrom
immer mehr menschen müssen auf der
kanaren insel la palma ihre häuser
aufgeben
die erste rede von us-präsident beiden
vor den vereinten nationen das wird er
sich anders an als bei seinem vorgänger
job nicht mehr america first sondern
america is back amerika ist zurück die
welt müsse wie niemals zuvor
zusammenhalten im kampf gegen
klimawandel und pandemie sagte biden
beides sind ohnehin zentrale themen des
treffens aus new york johannes hano es
waren für einen diplomaten selbst für
den un-generalsekretär ungewöhnlich
klare und eindringliche worte die
antonio guterres zur eröffnung der un
generalversammlung der welt entgegen
warf ein hier ich bin hier um alarm zu
schlagen die welt muss endlich aufwachen
wir stehen am abgrund und wir gehen in
die falsche richtung nie war unsere welt
bedrohter und nie so gespalten wir sind
konfrontiert mit mehr krisen als jemals
zuvor zu unseren lebzeiten
die weltweite pandemie die wachsende
schere zwischen arm und reich die sich
immer weiter verschärfen die klimakrise
könnten die welt über den abgrund
hinausführen mit großer spannung wurde
erwartet wie sich amerikas neuer
präsident soll sie ziehen ihren wird der
machte bei seiner ersten rede vor den
vereinten nationen eines klar
anstatt die kriege der vergangenheit zu
führen werden wir unsere augen auf die
schlüsselfragen richten die unsere
gemeinsame zukunft bestimmen werden
die pandemie beenden die klimakrise
angehen die veränderung der globalen
machtverhältnisse managen und die regeln
der welt zu formen in handels cyber und
technologiefragen
und er machte deutlich in welcher region
in zukunft amerikas prioritäten liegen
während die vereinigten staaten ihren
fokus verschieben auf die regionen wie
den indopazifischen raum die besonders
wichtig sind heute und in der zukunft
werden wir das mit unseren verbündeten
und partner tun
amerika hat sich in der weltgemeinschaft
heute zurück gemeldet aber die
blickrichtung hat sich verändert weg von
europa richtung asien
fragen wir noch mal nach bei unserem
korrespondenten johannes hano in new
york was bedeutet die rede beiden es
heute für europa und für deutschland
also ich glaube die rede bedeutet dass
europa lernen muss auf eigenen beinen zu
stehen wann ist zwar ganz froh darüber
dass amerika sich auf der weltbühne
zurück gemeldet hat dass man gemeinsam
klimakrise und auch die pandemie
bekämpfung wieder angehen kann aber joe
biden hat ihr ziemlich deutlich gemacht
dass amerikas fokus in zukunft in asien
liegen wir dort wo die größte
strategische bedeutung für amerika im
moment liegt dort sucht man neue
verbündete man hat china als größte
herausforderung ausgemacht und europa
ist er sehr weit weg dass man sich nicht
mehr allzu sehr um die befindlichkeiten
europas kümmert hat ja schon die
vergangenheit gezeigt die ja der
unangekündigte abzug aus afghanistan
oder der heimlich eingefädelte opel-deal
das ist irritieren und ernüchternd hatte
der deutsche außenminister heute ihr vor
der versammlung gesagt aber europa wird
lernen müssen in zukunft mehr selbst
verantwortung zu übernehmen und dann
wird sich nicht nur auf amerika als
ausputzer verlassen können danke nach
new yorkerin
im eigenen land steht der us-präsident
seit tagen gehörig unter druck vor allem
wegen solcher bilder
berittene us grenzschützer gehen gegen
flüchtlinge vor in der nähe der
texanischen kleinstadt will rio wo der
rio grande entlang der grenze zu mexiko
verläuft fast 15.000 menschen versuchen
von dort aus in die usa zu kommen die
meisten von ihnen stammen aus dem völlig
verarmten haiti claudia bates berichtet
wieder zurück nach mexiko durch den rio
grande
die angst treibt sie zurück die angst
von den usa abgeschoben zu werden viele
der flüchtlinge die in den letzten tagen
gekommen waren sind in ihre heimat
geflogen worden das wollen sie nicht
riskieren
sie schicken uns zurück in unser land
und wir haben dort nichts mehr wir haben
alles verkauft für die reise hierher
beim grenzort del rio im süden der usa
unter einer brücke suchen tausende
schutz vor der sengenden texanischen
sonne hier her sind sie gekommen in der
hoffnung auf asyl der us grenzschutz
völlig überfordert die migranten werden
brutal zurückgedrängt entsetzen über
dieses vorgehen die regierung will es
überprüfen macht aber gleichzeitig klar
dass die flüchtlinge hier unerwünscht
sind
wenn sie illegal in die usa kommen
werden sie zurück gebracht ihre reise
wird nicht erfolgreich sein und sie
gefährden ihr leben und das ihrer
familie
für präsident biden ist es mehr als ein
humanitäres problem es ist auch ein
politisches er hatte eine menschlichere
einwanderungspolitik versprochen der
linke flügel seiner demokraten fordert
jetzt taten die republikaner dagegen
finden seine politik zu lasch
es ist die aufgabe des bundes unsere
grenze zu sichern aber die beiden
regierung hat dabei versagt
präsident biden schweigt seine regierung
hat jetzt angekündigt im nächsten
haushaltsjahr
125000 flüchtlinge aufzunehmen
doppelt so viele wie in diesem jahr
nach deutschland und zur bundestagswahl
gut 60 millionen menschen sind am
sonntag aufgerufen ihre stimme abzugeben
davon sind 2,8 millionen erst
wählerinnen und erstwähler und auch eine
andere gruppe darf zum ersten mal wählen
dort der farbe hat mehr
bianca rats hat eine gesetzliche
betreuerin und bianca rat darf zur
bundestagswahl das ist neu sie bereitet
sich mit dem wahl-o-mat vor zur wald
selbst will sie sich von der betreuerin
begleiten lassen ein bisschen unsicher
bin dann kommen zur mitte aber
ankreuzen tue ich natürlich selber und
gehe auch leiden allein in der kabine
rein den erst wählenden des betreuten
wohnens werden die wahlunterlagen genau
erklärt mit der erststimme wird der
kandidat oder die kandidatin aus dem
wahlkreis direkt gewählt
299 solcher wahlkreise gibt es die
zweitstimme ist entscheidend für die
mehrheitsverhältnisse im parlament mit
ihr wird die landesliste einer partei
gewählt mit den kandidatinnen und
kandidaten die die partei in den
bundestag schicken will wer da
allerdings unsicher ist der kann
natürlich auch vor ort noch mal fragen
unsere wahlhelferinnen und wahlhelfer
sind geschult und können noch mal den
hinweis geben eine stimme je spalte in
den flutgebieten ist diese
bundestagswahl eine besondere
herausforderung in stolberg bei aachen
sind wahllokale wie hier zerstört worden
wählen können trotzdem alle
das wahllokal was ja eigentlich in dem
gebäude ist wird jetzt nach dem erlass
des landeswahlleiters in ein zelt vor
das gebäude verlegt in ein stabiles
zählt auch die korona regeln eingehalten
werden können wählen in corona zeiten
das heißt auch so viel briefwahl wie
noch nie in köln hat sich fast die
hälfte der wählenden dafür entschieden
die köpfe hinter dem chor ohne impfstoff
von biontech werden mit dem paul ehrlich
preis geehrt einem der bedeutendsten für
medizinische grundlagenforschung
uhr sahin und özlem tourette des gründer
ehepaar des unternehmens erhalten die
auszeichnung zusammen mit der
biochemikerin catalent carico sie hatten
den corona impfstoff in kürzester zeit
entwickelt auf basis der m rna
technologie mit der wird der körper des
patienten aktiviert spezielle stoffe
gegen erkrankungen herzustellen
möglich sein in den nächsten jahren so
auch krebs impfstoffe sagte slim türe
geht zum einen
und das seite sind als wichtige
zusätzliche säule weitere
schutzimpfungen gegen die richtigen
großen
infektionserkrankungen wie zum beispiel
malaria
tuberkulose und hiv
jetzt zu den aktuellen corona zeiten in
deutschland corona zahlen in deutschland
das robert koch institut meldet 4664
neue infektionen innerhalb von 24
stunden das sind
1661 weniger als vergangenen dienstag
die sieben tage incidents sinkt erneut
leicht auf
68,5
großer erschütterung hat der tod eines
20 jährigen in idar oberstein ausgelöst
der student war am wochenende bei seiner
arbeit in einer tankstelle erschossen
worden nachdem er offenbar einem kunden
ohne maske auf die masken pflicht
hingewiesen hatte der 49 jährige
mutmaßliche täter sagte der polizei er
lehne corona maßnahmen ab die politik
ist entsetzt und warnt vor einer
radikalisierung von corona leugnern anna
bruder und marion geiger
die kleine stadt idar oberstein in
trauer an dieser tankstelle wurde der
kassierer ein 20-jähriger student
erschossen tatverdächtig ist ein
49-jähriger mann er soll dem kassierer
in den kopf geschossen haben aus ärger
darüber dass er aufgefordert wurde eine
maske zu tragen zu dem motiv gab er an
dass ihnen die situation der korona
pandemie stark belaste er habe keinen
anderen ausweg gesehen als ein zeichen
zu setzen
dabei schien ihm auch das opfer
verantwortlich für die gesamtsituation
da es die regeln durchgesetzt habe die
machen dann fällt zwischen
verfassungsschutz war der täter bisher
nicht bekannt nach einer ersten analyse
heißt es verbindungen in extremistischen
bewegungen lägen nicht vor der
rheinland-pfälzische innenminister nennt
die tat einen feigen mord abgezeichnet
habe sie sich aber nicht
aber natürlich haben wir menschen die
sind gewaltbereit die treten aggressiv
auch in der öffentlichkeit auf auch im
hinblick auf diskussionen rund um kowitz
das ist festzustellen ja der
tatverdächtige soll mit einer waffe
geschossen haben für die er keinen
waffenschein hatte in seiner wohnung
fanden die ermittler weitere waffen und
munition jetzt während sein handy und
sein computer ausgewertet die tat
besorgt bundesweit ich bin schon sehr
neugierig darauf zu erfahren ob es sich
um jemanden handelt der psychisch
auffällig gewesen ist in der
vergangenheit oder jemand der in großen
anführungszeichen nur einer kundin
ideologie anhängt und dann tatsächlich
zu einem mörder wird gegen den
49-jährigen ist haftbefehl erlassen
worden wegen dringenden tatverdachts des
mordes aus niedrigen beweggründen
gibt es eine zunehmende radikalisierung
der korona leugne und der querdenker
bewegung das ist gleich thema bei zdf
heute live zu gast ist eine expertin für
verschwörungstheorien um 19 uhr 30 in
der zdf- heute- app und auf unseren
social media kanälen
ganz anderes thema jetzt demenz demenz
ist ein drama für alle betroffenen und
ihre angehörigen
1,6 millionen menschen leiden in
deutschland unter dieser veränderung des
gehirns sie verlieren zunehmend jede
erinnerung
bislang ist die krankheit nicht heilbar
zur woche der demenz zeigt anja chalet
wie eine familie in sachsen mit der
krankheit umgeht
christiane hartmann besucht ihre mutter
in einer wohn und pflegeeinrichtung in
dresden um ihr näher zu sein hatte die
91-jährige von greifswald nach sachsen
geholt die mutter hand demenz das blieb
lange verborgen
man merkt dass dann nur an kleinigkeiten
erst mal wenn man sich
wie ich wir haben uns ja nicht so häufig
gesehen ob das die hygiene ist oder das
essen kochen und das funktionierte dann
nicht mehr so wirklich
christiane hartmann hat sich hilfe
geholt bei der krankenkasse in einer
selbsthilfegruppe sie versucht zu
akzeptieren was es dafür braucht
geduld man muss denjenigen liebe
rüberbringen man muss zeit haben meine
tochter ist jetzt sehr viel da gewesen
ja das war sehr schön wundern ist man
nicht so ganz allein am leben teilhaben
und sehen was noch geht dafür macht sich
die landesinitiative demenz in sachsen
stark viele personen schämen sich viele
ziehen sich dann zurück und genau das
ist halt verkehrt die krankheit ist
bisher nicht teilbar medikamente früh
eingesetzt können prozesse nur
verlangsamen frühdiagnostik ist extrem
bedeutsam denn je schneller wir das
erkennen dass es sich um einen
krankhaften prozess handelt umso
schneller können wir eingreifen in
midrand rat gemalt liest wird klassische
musik die familie freut sich an den
schönen momenten die es auch mit der
krankheit gibt
auf der kanaren insel la palma bleibt
die lage nach dem vulkanausbruch
hochgefährlich seit drei tagen wälzt
sich die lava vom berg cumbria richtung
tal mittlerweile sind 160 häuser
verloren am frühen morgen hatte die erde
erneut gebebt am vulkan brach ein
weiterer riss auf anne arendt
faszination und entsetzen liegen nah
beieinander
feuerwehr und gemeindearbeiter
kontrollieren ob alle bewohner in
sicherheit sind am morgen hatte sich ein
neuer spalt im berg geöffnet
wenn die lava das meer erreicht hat
werden wir sehen welchen weg sie sich
gebannt hat und welche häuser
möglicherweise unversehrt geblieben sind
diese unsicherheit ist schlimm
denn der vulkanausbruch richtet immer
größere schäden an tausende sind bereits
vor feuer und glut geflohen spaniens
ministerpräsident sichert
unbürokratische hilfe zu
erst wenn la palma zur normalität
zurückgekehrt ist und alles was der
vulkan und die lava zerstört haben
wieder aufgebaut ist ist die katastrophe
überstanden
noch immer lässt sich das glühende
gestein die insel hinab gewarnt wird nun
zusätzlich vor giftigen gasen die beim
eintritt ins meer entstehen
die fußball nationalmannschaft der
frauen hat auch ihr zweites wm
qualifikationsspiel gewonnen leichten
anlaufschwierigkeiten norbert ja
allerdings aber nach der halbzeitpause
kamen sie dafür dann richtig auf touren
und das gilt vor allem für lehrer
schüler mit vier toren in folge sorgt
die stürmerin vom fc bayern münchen fast
im alleingang für den 5 2 1 erfolg gegen
serbien
zum naserümpfen war es für die
bundestrainerin was ihr team eine
halbzeit lang zeigte schon nach drei
minuten hieß es 1 zu 0 allerdings für
die serbischen gäste durch nina matthée
nach der pause stand urplötzlich eine
andere deutsche mannschaft auf dem platz
die schon bald durch lehrer schüler zum
ausgleich kam in der folge trug sich die
münchnerin noch drei weitere male ins
tor register ein und konnte so den
erwarteten größten unterschied zu den
serbinnen
auf weltranglistenplatz 41 aufzeigen
[Applaus]
den schlusspunkt zum 5 1 endstand setzte
sehenswert melanie leupolz nach zwei
spielen und 12 zu 1 toren hat das team
nun schon blickkontakt zur em in england
aufgenommen
tor rekorde hat er reichlich aufgestellt
nun hat robert lewandowski zum ersten
mal den goldenen schuh erhalten als
erfolgreichster torschütze europas in
der vergangenen saison der pole erzielte
elf treffer mehr als der zweitplatzierte
lionel messi die 41 eine magische zahl
in der bundesliga unerreicht der
dazugehörige treffer weniger magisch
erzielt in bester abstaubermanier nach
art des legendären gerd müller dessen 49
jahre alte rekord nun gebrochen ist seit
1972 wieder ein bundesliga profi europas
torjäger nummer eins robert lewandowski
33 jahre in der achten saison beim fc
bayern der goldene schuh zuletzt im
abonnement verliehen an lionel messi der
sechsmal und cristiano ronaldo der vier
mal die begehrte trophähe gewinnen
konnte pokale und trophäen machen ihnen
statt nur weiter hungrig in der jungen
saison ist lewandowski auch bereits bei
sieben treffern angekommen
wenn er so weiter macht genauso dann
landet er bei 47 bis 48
morgen beginnt der herbst und die kühlen
nächte passen dazu mehr zum wetter hat
gleich katja claus kleber begrüßt sie um
viertel vor zehn im heute-journal und
wir wünschen ihnen noch einen
unbeschwerten abend bis morgen wenn sie
mögen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
den abend hier von frankreich kommt das
hoch kerstin heran und deswegen gab es
die dichteren wolken heute eigentlich
nur hier im nordosten diese dichteren
wolken und osten brachten auch ein
bisschen regen mit aber für viele war
das doch schon ein sehr sonniger
spätsommertag übrigens der letzte
sommertag dieses jahres morgen beginnt
der astronomische der herbst heute nacht
fällt noch etwas regen hier zwischen
berlin brandenburg und dem erzgebirge
richtung südwesten lockert es dagegen
auf da bildet sich auch mal nebel und es
wird kalt die temperaturen sinken auf 7
bis 3 grad örtlich droht also bodenfrost
milder bleibt die nacht unter den wolken
im nordosten und an der see bei 13 bis 9
grad die höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen zwischen 14 grad in den östlichen
mittelgebirgen und 21 grad ganz im
westen zum beispiel auf den
ostfriesischen inseln oder auch am rhein
und am rhein und westlich davon da
strahlt morgen die sonne richtung
nordosten sind die wolken dichter
regentropfen sind aber so gut wie
ausgeschlossen
am donnerstag dann wird es sehr windig
an der see da droht der erste
herbststurm bei temperaturen von 16 bis
23 grad der freitag wird dann schon sehr
sonnig und am samstag gibt es sogar
nochmal sommer temperaturen bis 25 grad
guten abend